[Music]
interspecies love nicotine addiction
adult jokes and who is actually a genius
and actually insane these are all things
you may have missed as a kid but now
that you're an adult it's time to
revisit pinky in the brain with fresh
eyes
injecting an educational topics into
saturday morning cartoons can be a real
challenge but both animaniacs and pinky
and the brain were exceptionally good at
doing so both shows were known for using
catchy musical numbers and creative
humor to teach viewers a thing or two
about the world
and one notable example the song a
meticulous analysis of history features
pinky in the brain describing cleopatra
hannibal attila the hun caligula
napoleon bonaparte and other historical
conquerors kids will certainly remember
the catchy tune in some famous names
even if a lot of the details may not
leave an impression other references are
a little less obvious and take both a
keen year and some history lessons to
pick up on the show's christmas special
sneaks in an indelicate joke about one
of the most infamous events of the
look rain 1800s reindeers are inviting
elves to join them for a party at
donna's house
somehow the idea of joining the donner
party is unappealing
needless to say this reference to a
group of cannibalistic pioneers wasn't
really meant for kids to understand
animated kids shows have a long history
of making pop culture references and
pinky in the brain is certainly no
exception kids can easily pick up on
references to things like winnie the
pooh and the macarena but there are some
things that will almost certainly go
over their heads for instance bill
grates and micro sponge from the episode
snowball are in reference to bill gates
and microsoft the feebles and all you
need is narf parody the beatles while
the title of the episode pays homage to
the fab fours all you need is love other
kids shows may have referenced the
beatles before but pinky in the brain
goes a step further and spooks john
lennon's wife yoko ono the character of
yo-yo nono adults watching the episode
are able to pick out the real facts from
the satirical retelling of events while
kids stick around for the silly jokes
even brain himself is a reference to
someone that those on the younger side
are unlikely to recognize the pint-sized
genius was designed to look and sound
like orson welles the legendary actor
and director who passed away 10 years
before pinkie and the brain first aired
in nearly every single episode of the
show the brain asked pinkie the exact
same question are you pondering what i'm
pondering of course pinky's response is
always unpredictable and usually gets a
laugh from the audience in fact some of
his quips are even a little off base
with some inappropriate implications
popping up now and then pinky's
ponderings have included a plan to get a
tattoo a suggestion to marry regis
philbin and multiple mentions of
dressing animals in suggestive clothing
pinky are you pondering what i'm
pondering i think so brain but what if
the hippopotamus won't wear the beach
thong
to an innocent mind these jokes might
not seem so cheeky but when it comes to
the mind of an adult it's really easy to
wind up in the gutter even brain seems
to recognize this himself
are you pondering what i'm pondering i
think so blaine but i get all clammy
inside the tent
sigmund freud would have had a field day
with you pinky
at first glance pinky in the brain's
relationship appears to be that of
co-workers who share the common goal of
total world domination when we take a
closer look at their interactions
however it's clear that pinky and the
brain actually care very deeply for one
another the ever faithful pinky is
always ready to go along with brain's
crazy plans no matter how impossible or
embarrassing they might seem the paris
friendship is put to the ultimate test
in a pinky and the brain halloween in
the episode brain is forced to choose
between saving pinky's soul and
achieving his lifelong dream of ruling
the world to the audience's surprise
brain chooses to try and save pinky and
even though he claims that it was only
because his cohort knows the location of
their food pellets it's obvious that
things aren't quite that simple the two
also find themselves filling parental
roles in multiple episodes in two mice
and a baby they take on the task of
raising a superhuman son with pinky as
the mother figure and brain as the
father the same rules reappear in the
episode brinky and this time the couple
is in charge of raising their biological
offspring they pull off these roles with
relative comfort and ease leaving the
audience with a few questions as to the
true nature of their relationship
brain's overly complex plans often
include him and pinky having to play
dress-up in several episodes they end up
disguising themselves as female
characters and they often do so quite
successfully in the episode brain boogie
brain dresses up in a comically
long-legged share outfit in order to
compete in a golfing tournament on more
than one occasion the two disguise
themselves as women even when it doesn't
seem like the easiest option for example
in whatever happened to baby brain brain
takes on the persona of adorable starlet
baby brain a character modeled after
america's little darlene shirley temple
when it comes time for baby brain to
sign a contract after finally making her
big break brain tells the producer that
pinkie is her mother even though
pinkie's gender presentation has nothing
to do with the success of their plan and
a little off the top pinky doesn't skip
a beat when brain orders him to dress up
and seduce samson distracting him so
brain can steal a ring from the biblical
warrior then in my feldman's my friends
pinkie takes on the role of brain's wife
so the pair can infiltrate their
neighbor's house and steal the final
piece they need for their doomsday
device the theme song for pinky and the
brain is one of the catchiest openings
any cartoon has to offer but one line is
particularly memorable one is a genius
the other is insane it seems obvious
that the mouse called brain would be the
smart one after all the intro sequence
shows pinkie's skull nearly empty while
brain's head is full of moving gears
however some fans have a theory that the
truth might not be so simple
in the episode pinkie's turn brain
finally gives pinkie the chance to come
up with his own plan to take over the
world while brain's plans almost always
end in failure and humiliation pinkie's
plan is so successful that he becomes
chairman of the federal reserve and
replaces the us dollar with fruit snacks
in another episode pinkie's plan pinkie
convinces the most powerful world
leaders to hand over the keys to their
nations something the so-called genius
was never able to do finally there's
that famous quote from albert einstein
which could almost certainly apply to
brain
insanity is doing the same thing over
and over again and expecting different
results
we're not here to pass judgment on pinky
but it's pretty obvious that the guy has
a thing for horses after all he was
quick to defend caligula's rather
intimate relationship with his horse in
a meticulous analysis of history
what's wrong with being friendly with a
thorough bread
additionally during a segment from the
animaniacs called jockey for position
pinkie falls in love with a racehorse
named farfight newton evidence in later
episodes of pinkie and the brain and the
animaniacs movie wacko's wish proved
that this horse is in fact pinkie's
girlfriend and in the third mouse pinkie
isn't ashamed to defend his love for the
mayor
people are so intolerant
to kids this relationship may not seem
all that unusual since well the show was
a cartoon but many adults in the
audience have recognized that pinky and
farfig newton's relationship is
representative of something bigger and
much more real the writers use pinkie's
quirky love life as a vehicle for
showing that diverse relationships
should be acceptable in our society
the creators of pinky and the brain
loved to fill their episodes with
parodies of celebrities portrayed by
professional voice actors but some
famous figures were more than happy to
voice animated versions of themselves
and the pinky and the brain reunion
special for instance both dick clark and
dr joyce brothers make appearances as
unwitting accomplices to brain's
nefarious scheme
of course younger viewers are unlikely
to know the difference between most of
these cameos and impressions or know who
joyce brothers is anyway however
celebrities wouldn't always play
versions of themselves sometimes they
would play original fictional characters
mark hamill carrie ellis and pam greer
have all shown up at one point or
another as part of the sneaky
star-studded cast list both of pinkie's
parents are even voiced by eric idol of
monty python fan
it's unusual for a children's cartoon to
take on the task of conveying truly
adult issues such as drug use sexual
harassment accusations politics and
addiction in an honest but still
entertaining manner well that didn't
stop the team behind pinky in the brain
in the award-winning episode inherit the
wheeze brain becomes addicted to smoking
cigarettes after being tested on in the
lab when he begins experiencing the
sickly side effects firsthand he decides
to become a spokesperson to ultimately
raise awareness around the severity of
health risks associated with smoking
that's not the only time brain deals
with addiction either and meglo maniacs
anonymous brain joins a support group
for people addicted to trying to take
over the world only for the meetings to
have the opposite effect on top of all
of that the show is also no stranger to
the world of politics with names like
rush limbaugh bill clinton and al gore
coming up much more often than one might
expect
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]